[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday and if i may i'd like
to extend a special welcome to our
viewers in ukraine and russia to you
dobrevo ranco and debroyo utro
there's only one topic for us this
morning we're told that the authorities
in moscow ordered our journalistic
colleagues there not to refer to what
has taken place as an invasion
well here at sky we tend to describe a
spade as a spade so we will be talking
about the russian invasion of its
independent sovereign neighbor ukraine
does doesn't independent ukraine still
exist this morning
and if it does for how long can it hold
out against the russian invasion
we're joined by a range of guests to try
to cut through the fog of war and to
discuss what it means for us here at
home up first i'll be speaking to the
foreign secretary liz truss
next in a week where labour has pledged
to show unity with the government
against russia's actions
we'll hear from the shadow foreign
secretary david lammy
as the military situation unfolds we'll
get the assessment of the threat posed
by russia on the ground under the sea
and in cyberspace from general sir chris
deverell former head of the uk's joint
forces command
will sanctions be enough to stop
vladimir putin we'll get the view of
brian o'toole a former u.s treasury
official who helped design and
coordinate the sanctions against russia
after the annexation of crimea in 2014
and we'll hear from alicia kearns
conservative member of the commons
foreign affairs committee who visited
ukraine earlier this year
and how is the invasion being viewed in
moscow
could it turn out to be a boost for
opponents of the russian president i'll
speak to vladimir karamorza a leading
russian opponent of vladimir putin
and we'll look at the wider impact of
the conflict on the global economy and
on the pocket of consumers with vicki
price former chief government economist
but first let's talk to the foreign
secretary liz truss who joins me in a
studio good morning foreign secretary
um
where is the military balance this
morning
well what we're seeing is we're seeing
that the ukrainian forces
are continuing to resist
russian advances
we haven't seen
overnight significant changes
in what is happening on the ground but
we are seeing i think unexpected by the
russians very very strong and brave
ukrainian resistance and it's our role
as key supporters of ukraine to continue
to supply them with defensive weapons
continue to supply them with economic
support to help them resist this
egregious invasion to what extent do you
think that uh mr putin
has failed to object his first well
three-day objectives
we
said before this invasion took place
that vladimir putin would be making a
massive strategic mistake
first of all because the ukrainians
would fight and we're seeing them fight
we're seeing the incredibly brave
leadership of president zielenski
but also because they would be hit
by severe western sanctions and last
night the g7 agreed that we would cut
access for russia to the swift banking
system that we would target the russian
central bank that would be putting more
sanctions on oligarchs and companies and
you can see the reaction in the
international markets you can see the
damage already to the russian economy
but i fear trevor that this will be a
long haul
what i'm saying though is that the
united kingdom absolutely stands by
ukraine through this very long and
difficult conflict by the way when you
talked about long haul it's reported
this morning you said that this could be
ten years
this could be a number of years because
what we do know
is russia have strong forces but we know
that the ukrainians are brave that
they're determined to stand up for their
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and they're determined to fight
and the sanctions that we are putting in
place and they are very very tough
sanctions
cutting the russian economy at its knees
cutting access to the western system you
know we've banned aeroflot from flying
into the united kingdom
we're targeting key oligarchs we've got
a hit list of oligarchs but these will
take time
to have an effect and debilitate the
russian economy we need to wean
europe off
russia and oil and gas this will take
time so this is not going to be a fear
over quickly but we need to be prepared
for a very long haul i want to come to
the sanctions question in a moment but
um sticking with a military issue
what actual military support are we
offering to ukraine
so we've trained up 20 000 ukrainian
soldiers uh we've put support into the
ukrainian navy
we've supplied anti-tank weapons
which are being used by the ukrainians
and we continue to supply
defensive weaponry for the ukrainians to
use we've also led the defense secretary
led a donor conference on friday with 25
other countries they have pledged also
to support and last night we saw that
germany has changed its position germany
is now going to be supplying defensive
weapons into ukraine so we're seeing a
huge uptick and britain really has led
in this we were the first country in
europe to supply defensive weapons to
ukraine we're now seeing others supply
defensive weapons as well and this is
vitally important to help the ukrainians
resist
the russian invasion and the russian
advance what we're also seeing is just
the huge motivation
of the ukrainian forces you know they
are fighting for their country but
they're also fighting for freedom and
democracy and it's vitally important
that putin's ambitions stop in ukraine
you know he's he's stated publicly that
you know he wants to regain control of
vast ways of eastern europe whether it's
poland moldova the baltics we must make
sure that we are doing all we can to
back the ukrainian resistance
there's clearly as you say great
resistance here
but
one of the things that i think is now
being contemplated is
if the russians feel that they are being
frustrated their response might not be
to step back it might be to deploy
greater firepower
how serious do you think this could
become
i fear you are absolutely right trevor
we've already seen
uh the response from the russian
government
we've seen the actions taken despite
all of the warnings about the severe
cost of this conflict in terms of
humanitarian costs in terms of cost for
the russian state i mean this could well
be
uh the beginning of the end for putin
and i fear that he is determined to use
the most unsavory means uh in this war
but he should be aware
that the international criminal court is
already looking at what is happening in
ukraine and
there will be serious consequences for
him personally and for the russian
government how far do you think he can
go i mean he has
chemical biological weapons he has
nuclear weapons how
bloody could this actually become i fear
this conflict could be very very bloody
and we've already seen
uh
civilians targeted uh by by the russian
by the russian government i urge the
russians not to escalate this conflict
but we do need to be prepared for russia
to
seek to use
even worse weapons i think it would be
hugely devastating russia is already
isolated internationally the un security
council not a single country
voted with russia
everybody is dissociating themselves
from russia they have been cut off from
the international community financially
diplomatically
politically and that would simply make
it even worse we saw in syria the use of
chemical weapons uh banned weapons
could that be a factor here and uh you
know one doesn't want to overdramatize
this but let's be frank
ukraine was the site of many what used
to be called battlefield nuclear weapons
are we talking at in the worst in worst
circumstances that kind of carnage
we need to avoid this at all costs this
is why it is so important the work we
are doing to degrade the russian
military complex we're stopping
the export of technologies to russia we
are stopping the ability of those
military companies to raise money in the
international markets we're cutting off
uh the swift system from russia
precisely so that they cannot fund this
war machine anymore
we have said that we're standing
shoulder to shoulder we are going to do
everything for ukrainians well of course
one of the consequences of this action
even before any of the kinds of things
we've just been talking about happens
will be a flow of refugees 150 000
apparently have left un talked about 5
million some of those people will want
to come
here
what are we going to do
to admit those people from ukraine who
maybe have families here at the moment
the visa regime
seems
extremely bureaucratic and restrictive
have you any thought about how it's
going to be made easier for people to
flee
well the prime minister has already been
very clear that we are a country that
welcomes refugees that we will do all we
can to support the ukrainians we're
already putting in a lot of humanitarian
assistance
at the border of course the main thing
we can do is support the ukrainians to
fight for their country so that they can
have a long-term future in ukraine
that's extremely important trevor but
telling people whose families are here
who are ukrainian
who want to bring their families out
that you have to apply for a seasonal
work visa does not sound that welcoming
we are looking at what more we can do
trevor the prime minister was very clear
last night that we will will be
welcoming refugees from ukraine we're
already expediting our visa processes
our passport processes we've got a 24 7
operation running at the foreign office
helping people with emergency travel
documents
but i can tell you trevor we are looking
at what more we can do come on you're
better we're saying we'll be saying more
about this very shortly well i hope you
you might want to say something about
that today because right today people in
ukraine are saying we have to travel to
live to get a visa in ukraine if we want
a british visa we have to get out of
ukraine to poland or romania or moldova
that is not easy that is not welcoming
why not simply say that people who can
get from ukraine to here who have
relatives who have a place to go
will have at least a temporary visa and
then you can do the investigations and
all of that why not be clear about it
today because in
in kiev what they're hearing is the
british aren't that keen on you coming
well first of all i can completely say
that is not true the united kingdom does
welcome refugees and we want to do all
we can to support ukraine
economically we're supporting the
humanitarian effort i had a call last
night with the united nations about how
we support uh making sure the
humanitarian
response is completely in place how we
protect humanitarian corridors out of
ukraine so we are doing
all that work
i know it's difficult and i completely
appreciate the difficult of
communications in ukraine there is an
online system that people can use uh to
apply for visas but as i say we are
looking urgently trevor we're looking
urgently at what more we can do to
support people in ukraine but i want to
send a very strong message
the united kingdom
welcomes refugees our people on the
ground in ukraine are not
i are hearing from people in ukraine
that that is not the message they're
hearing what they're hearing is it's
difficult to come to britain and what
after they've come complained that we're
a bit slow and getting the weapons and
all the rest of it
it's not a great look for us is it
well can i just pull you up on the point
about the defensive weapons we were the
first we were the first
we were the first european country
to send
defensive weapons to ukraine
we have had a long-term program of
training up the ukrainian armed forces
we're now seeing other european
countries also send defensive weapons
which is very welcome we were the first
country to call for swift to be cut out
from the russians we have put in the
toughest package of sanctions of any
european country so we will always lead
and we will also lead trevor on the
humanitarian and the refugee effort and
i can guarantee that to you today all
right let's come on to your ground which
is a diplomatic territory uh there is uh
reports there are reports that the
belarusians have uh tried to open some
conversation with uh the ukrainians
today what do we know of that and what
do you think this means
well what we know is throughout the
diplomatic discussions we've been having
the russians have lied
when i was in moscow i was assured by
sergey lavrov there would be no invasion
of ukraine that was not true president
putin said there wouldn't be no invasion
of ukraine that is not true so what we
know
is that the russians weren't and aren't
serious about diplomacy this is why our
efforts should be focused on supporting
the ukrainians
fighting ukraine to defend their country
and cutting off the russian economy from
the international system and degrading
the russian economy now if the russians
are serious
about negotiations they need to remove
their troops from ukraine
they cannot negotiate with a gun to the
head of the ukrainians they need to
remove their troops which is what they
call for they need to de-escalate this
conflict and i see absolutely no signs
of that we're continuing to see a
russian offensive in ukraine so frankly
i don't trust
these so-called efforts of negotiation
so no talks until there's a with
complete withdrawal absolutely
uh
we talked to you've talked about the
sanctions uh already um
in yuval you and i have discussed this
uh those sanctions before you've
obviously had some success with getting
uh other countries to
do something about the swift system
the other sanctions uh
that we might be looking at are for
example in relation to uh energy um
in 2014 david cameron along with other
european leaders vowed to reduce our
dependence on russian energy supplies
in 2014 we in the uk actually bought
zero cubic meters
from russia
in
the last year we bought 6.4 billion
cubic meters they have to be a rocket
scientist to know that actually
we applied sanctions but in fact we
bought more
gas from russia why is it going to be
any different this time
so we currently i think three percent of
our energy supplies are a russian gas
which is a lot lower uh than many many
european countries i mean some are up to
85
of all their gas comes from russia so
what we need to do
is we need to agree
with our g7 counterparts because we're
not going to be able to do this alone we
need to agree to reduce that percentage
over time
that that's what's important so i would
support the idea of having ceilings on
how much
oil and gas is imported from russia so
over time we cut uh the dependency right
across europe and that's what we're
working with our g7 partners but you're
absolutely right trevor
that the west
did not follow through yeah and that is
why
that is why that's why we're in the
situation we're in now
is we didn't do enough
to deter putin
in 2008 and 2014 and that is why our
sanctions will be much tougher
that is why
the germans in particular have cancelled
nordstrom 2 they're now supplying
defensive weapons we've seen a huge
change which i very much welcome because
we need to take a different approach
we simply cannot afford to be importing
russia and oil and gas we cannot afford
to have
such a strong russian presence in our
financial system that is why we're
prepared to take tough actions that will
ultimately be difficult for our economy
in the short term but will help protect
freedom and democracy in the long term
yes but i i if i may say so
i think that that all sounds right and
good but the problem is that it went in
the wrong direction last time
you have to work with other people and i
suppose we're not going to get let it go
in the wrong direction this time i am
absolutely determined trevor the prime
minister is absolutely determined not to
let it happen again
brian o'toole who was the treasury
official charged with essentially
leading on the
devising sanctions regime after 2014
uh said to me in the interview we're
going to run later in this program that
actually you have to understand there
are limits to what sanctions can do
they could they knew that they couldn't
get putin out of crimea in 2014 with
sanctions what they hoped to do and what
he thought they did was to delay further
aggressions what is our real objectives
with sanctions here he's not going to be
back out of ukraine because of sanctions
is he the real objective is to degrade
the russian economy
because what we know is that putin's war
machine is funded by revenues from oil
and gas so what we have to do is reduce
dependency on oil and gas we have to cut
the ability
of russia to raise money on the
international financial markets we're
cutting the technology that they can use
in their military complex they've got
very advanced weapons we're going to
stop them accessing western technology
so over a period of time it's harder and
harder for putin to fund his army harder
and harder for him to create that new
technology and harder harder and harder
for him to wage war but i completely
agree with your analysis that this will
take time all right this is why i'm
saying this is a lot going to be a
long-running conflict the ukrainians are
and will resist it's very very hard for
russia to gain permanent control over
ukraine when the public of ukraine do
not want that and that is what this is
why we warn putin that this would be a
long-running quagmire but the role of
sanctions is degrading the russian
economy over time all right let's talk
about a couple of things that we can do
um
when again we spoke you said that there
would be nowhere to hide for putin's
associates the oligarchs now roman
abramovich has relinquished control of
chelsea football club but he still owns
it
and that means that if you come after
his assets for an example if you were to
come after his assets
chelsea football club would be beyond
your re reach in truth
unless you change the way that all
companies operate in london the
oligarchs and their british lawyers will
still be able to protect their assets
won't they
well this week we'll be introducing the
economic crime bill which will create a
lot more transparency
around the structures of these companies
and make it much clearer uh what is
going on i've compiled a hit list of
oligarchs people who is abramovic on it
i'm not going to say who is on the list
but what i can tell you
is there are over a hundred billionaires
in russia
we have compiled a hit list of oligarchs
we're working through and putting the
cases together and every few weeks we
will sanction new oligarchs there will
be a rolling program of sanctions we
will go through the hit list we're
targeting oligarchs private jets uh
we'll be targeting their properties uh
we'll be targeting uh other possessions
that they have and there will be nowhere
to hide
all right look um
lastly everyone knows newton's law to
every action there's a reaction we have
we'll do the sanctions and so on
it's estimated that energy bills might
now climb to three thousand
we can expect inflation above eight
percent ukraine produces grain price of
bread will rise so there will be a cost
to all of this
for us
i wonder um
for us to make a difference
our people are going to have to
face some suffering
uh some consequences
are you going to level with the british
people that in order to force change in
moscow
people in manchester and maidstern and
bertha tidfield anywhere else begins
with m are going to make sacrifices in
this country as for what neville
chamberlain once described as a quarrel
in a far away country between people of
which we know
nothing
are you going to be clear with britain
that if we're going to
fight this long
battle they are going to have to
sacrifice
well first of all the sacrifices that we
are going to have to undertake in
britain are nothing like the sacrifices
that people in ukraine are suffering now
they are having to arm themselves they
are having to fight on the streets
due to a completely unprovoked invasion
by the russians and my thoughts are with
the people of ukraine and the difficult
struggle
that they they they have ahead of them
but we're not just fighting for the
people of ukraine and the sovereignty
and self-determination of ukraine
this
long-running
conflict is about freedom and democracy
in europe
because if we don't stop putin in
ukraine
we are going to see others under threat
the baltics
poland moldova
and it could end up in a conflict with
nato we do not want to go there that is
why it's so important that we make the
sacrifices now and yes there will be an
economic cost here in britain there will
be a cost in terms of
access to oil and gas markets we don't
import much here but
there are
there are a lot of um
imports into
a continental europe from russian gas so
inevitably there will be impacts but
we have to
and i i firmly believe the british
public
understand the price we would pay if we
don't stand up to peter now
the price we would pay
is much greater in the long term and
frankly
over the past 15 years we haven't done
enough to stand up to putin we're now
facing the reality of what that means
and that is why we are taking a much
tougher stand now
liz trust thank you very much thank you
we've plenty more coming up but if you
want the latest on the ukraine invasion
while you watch us you can scan the qr
code on the screen right now which will
take you to the very latest from our
teams on the ground and beyond
vladimir putin seeks division so we must
stand united the words of labour leader
sakir stama earlier in the week
but what are the limits to the
opposition's willingness to support the
government's measures against russia and
where do they think further action
should be taken
joining me now from central london is
the shadow foreign secretary
david lammy
david lama you heard
what
liz trust had to say about the military
situation this morning um do you differ
in your assessment uh of where we are at
all
i'm sorry trevor can you repeat that
question i couldn't hear it yes uh i
think you heard what liz trust said
about the military situation this
morning that though the russians may
have suffered some reverses there is
still
if you like a pretty uh heavy bet to be
made that they will continue and they
may even
use greater firepower do you differ at
all in your assessment of uh the
military situation
uh than compared to what she said
look we've got to support uh ukraine as
much as we can i'm pleased to see the
announcement
from germany
overnight and of course it's important
that there is that military equipment to
fight on the ground i think all of us
have been hugely emboldened by the
bravery of president zielinski and the
ukrainian people
and very clearly we also have to
increase
our troops on the eastern flank of nato
to support the baltic states
and to hope that vladimir putin steps
back from what he's doing in ukraine but
also of course his threats that he's
made to the baltic states
do you really think that uh there's a
possibility that he might step back
well look uh the sanctions that are
coming into place are very very
important to squeeze his finances and
his ability to wage war
i raised last week
that we should be placing sanctions on
semi conductors that he needs for his
military equipment there's more that i
hope the government will do in the
coming days in that area but importantly
uh he has not met his objectives
in the first four days of this conflict
he's not met those objectives because
the ukrainians have taken up arms and we
must support them in that endeavor so i
hope that over the coming days he will
step back and of course it's important
because this is now square to square
with nato
that he steps back from any conflict
that goes beyond the borders of ukraine
do you
put any credit in the approach that's
been made in belarus this morning
well belarus has allowed its country to
be used for the stationing of russian
troops who are attempting to enter the
country uh i'm not sure that they will
be seen as a
fair-handed broker in this regard the
only thing that should happen now
is that the russian army lay down their
troops and exit ukraine
then the talking can resume i've got to
say when you're seeing missiles fired
on civilian housing blocks when you're
seeing children dying in this conflict
it's hard it's hard to see belarus as an
honest broker
okay uh it seems to me that you're one
with government on that your colleague
yvette cooper however has been critical
this morning the government's response
on to the likely demand for visas from
people
uh in ukraine what precisely would you
like the government to do how should the
visa regime be changed
look the government have got a visa
scheme it's bureaucratic there's a lot
of red tape it's success
insisting that people demonstrate
salaries that they have family ties to
this country people are fleeing with
their children in their arms why would
you ask people how rich they are to
enter our country of course there are
some people who may not have family ties
but want to come into this country no we
should have a scheme and a process
that's similar to the scheme that we had
after the balkans that's as generous as
the schemes that we've had in the past
when we allowed people to flee idiomine
from uganda when we allow people to flee
conflict in cyprus when we allow the
vietnamese boat people to enter our
country that's the sort of generosity
that the british people expect and
frankly uh suggesting that people should
use
this scheme that
effectively fruit pickers come to this
country on it is totally totally
unacceptable
so you would say that we should
essentially
open the doors to people
who are uh coming out of the ukraine or
coming out of uh neighboring states
bearing in mind the un's talked about
five million
potential refugees
we need a safe sanctuary scheme
similar to the one that we had after the
balkans
uh trevor at the vast majority of
refugees will want to settle in hungary
in poland in the baltic states that is
the estimation of the un but there are
some people who will want to make their
way to our country for whatever reason
and of course we should have a
simplified process a simplified scheme
as we're seeing other colleagues doing
in the un not a scheme with lots of
bureaucracy lots of red tape and
effectively that tells people that they
should come as occasional workers and
pick our fruit that is not the
generosity you expect of our country
in matters of war and it is not
consistent frankly with what we have
done in the past when people have been
fleeing conflict
all right let's talk about some of the
things that labour has proposed your
leader said yesterday
that the uh russian ambassador should be
thrown out of this country how would
that help
he came to parliament a few weeks ago
and we asked him
what is russia doing with troops on the
border he denied that russia was
building troops has russia got plans to
come into the country uh he said no they
do not want to invade ukraine we've had
lie after lie and just as other
countries have said look to their
ambassadors leave our country it is time
for him to leave our country
well uh i don't want to
make too big a thing about this but i
think it was the british who coined the
phrase that a diplomat is a man a person
sent abroad to life for his country but
let me just ask you again what how would
that make any difference to the people
of ukraine uh and who would if there was
no russian ambassador who would you pick
up the phone to to
pursue the diplomatic channels that
you've been talking about
trevor
uh we are currently in a situation
effectively of war from russia to
ukraine that's what we've got
uh we are now going to cut russia out of
the financial system
uh the posture of vladimir putin will be
very
old our relationship sorry with vladimir
putin will be very hard to recover over
the coming the coming weeks because
clearly um
clearly he is determined if you listen
to him uh to exact a price on the
ukrainian government
and he is threatening in relation to the
west of course given the lies that he
has told consistent with the pariah
state that russia has now become no
country in the un supporting this action
we should say to his russian ambassador
that he should leave the country
okay well i i think the re the question
i'm really asking is about um
the things where you appear to differ
from the government i'm really trying to
get some idea about the proportionality
of the measures that you are proposing
uh you've issued a press release this
morning in the name of
rachel reeves yourself and um
nicholas simmons smith who i think
actually i think that's actually
not to nicolas simmons smith is it it's
another
labour front venture
i just wanted to check the sanctions
letter that myself
there's a sanctions letter that myself
and rachel reeves have issued this
morning uh we are saying that we think
there should be more banks listed uh we
can't understand why it's still the case
that there are major banks that are not
subject to russian banks that are not
subject to sanctions we've raised issues
about the sectors including insurance
should be included it should not be
possible for vladimir putin to
effectively de-risk
his war escapade
in ukraine we're concerned about family
members of some of those oligarchs you
heard from this trust her saying that
she wants to bring forward a hundred
names where are those names there are
names on the us list that are not on the
uk list
why aren't we banning the export of
luxury goods so those are the issues
that we're raising this morning and that
we will scrutinize with the government
when they bring forward their further
plans for sanctions in parliament
tomorrow all right so
i raised the issue of the name because
um
actually the third person on that is i
think nick thomas simons who's your
trade spokesperson and the first thing
that you have proposed in that letter is
a
ban on the export of luxury goods and
you refer to the list of uh banned
luxury goods that was drawn up in the
syrian conflict um
is it genuinely your contention that if
we deprive mr putin
of jaguar cars wedgewood crockery and
chocolate truffles which are the only
three things on that list which he can
only pretty much get from britain that
that's going to change his mind
trevor with all seriousness we have been
raising consistently
implementing in full the russia report
dealing with my point is actually about
seriously dealing with those
coming on your list of course in
relation to luxury goods we're talking
about oligarchs that's the first
my question is do you think that will
actually change anybody's mind
it's part of a package of messages that
of course we've been calling for and
that includes the export of luxury goods
alongside all of those banks many of
which aren't mentioned alongside naming
the hundred oligarchs dealing with those
entities dealing with family members all
of it consistent with us cutting russia
out of the financial system and
squeezing putin the people around him
and indeed the ability for him to
finance war squeezing him very hard
indeed
shadow foreign secretary thank you very
much
thank you
let's get some analysis now of the
russian military operation so far and
the questions they pose for the uk
and nato joining me now is the chris
deveral former commander of the uk's
joint forces command
good morning general um
you've commanded an armored brigade um
what's your assessment of the success or
otherwise of mr putin's invasion plan to
date
well good morning trevor it's uh it's
great to be with you on this sunny
sunday morning but i think these are
dark days for europe
i think it's a bit early to draw
conclusions about the um success or
otherwise of the russian campaign we're
actually only four days into the
conflict i think it's possible that the
russians have some logistic issues um
and it is likely that the ukrainians are
fighting back hard
but i also think that at some point
it's likely that the russians will take
control of kiev they're not without a
fight
do you think um
the the machine seems to have stalled do
you think that just purely to do
with ukrainian resistance or are there
other factors supply lines and all of
that kind of thing
yeah i'm sure all of that bears on on
what's happening it's also russian
doctrine
to develop overwhelming force on
specific axes of advance rather than to
advance on a wide front
if they can take control of cities
through special force attacks they will
do so but otherwise i would expect them
to avoid
trying to take cities until they have
significant numbers available because
because street fighting consumes large
numbers of troops
well indeed um and that would be the big
prize wasn't it kiev or kharkiv um
how bloody is that likely to get
well um
i think that
yeah it's hard to say
because it will in the end depend upon
how hard the ukrainians fight i think
they've given every indication they
intend to fight hard so i think it could
be very bloody
i don't think it's easy to invest a city
and take a city uh where the defenders
are and determined in their opposition
without a lot of bloodshed
and i think you know the evidence is
that
putin's life depends upon making ukraine
into a client state so he's all in
so at the end of the day i don't think
he's going to
uh restrict his use of weaponry or or
tactics uh to achieve his name
you think that if he uh encounters
greater resistance
that actually what he'll do is step up
the firepower it's
i think what some people call the
cornered rat problem
um
yeah i think i think um
we do have to bear in mind that
um a corner of rat is very dangerous so
we need to to be thoughtful about
backing putin into a desperate corner
but on the other hand you know i also
think that he's a playground bully
and playground bullies ultimately only
understand hard power so i think we have
to
be extremely determined in our language
and our deployments as far as nato is
concerned that we will not tolerate any
uh extension of this campaign beyond
the ukraine and that we will support the
ukrainian armed forces in their fight
against russia
do you think there are more that there
is more that we could do to achieve
that end to or to give them support
i i think that um
the the difficulty obviously is that if
we give them direct military support
then um pretty quickly we are at war
with russia and i do think uh that we
need to avoid that that would be a very
significant escalation of the conflict
and it's hard to see where it would end
so i think that
the kinds of things that we're doing at
the moment uh are our rights that we
need to continue them and and increase
them
supplying um weapons in particular um to
the ukrainian armed forces
liz trust uh spoke this morning with me
about
the uh length that this conflict might
uh go on she's obviously contemplating
years actually
um ukraine is a big place it's
gr area four times the size of england
um
gaining control of cities might be one
thing but holding the country is another
how
bigger set of forces would the russians
have to commit and do you think
they can
they might be able to win this conflict
but can they hold it
yeah i mean i am a bit baffled by this
point um
i i think that putin may well have
enough troops to take control of
uh large sways of the country to to um
bring to a point the end of the direct
military confrontation but i just can't
see how he has enough troops
to maintain that control
across a country of 44 million people
the size it is
even with extraordinary violent
repression which i'm sure he would he
would use especially since um
the people were are never going to
forgive him um and
lots of other countries will likely lend
support to an insurgency so i i must say
i don't understand
how he thinks this ends well for him i
think he's made an absolutely
major miscalculation
so you think that there may be strategic
errors here i mean there is some
conversation going on about
why does he why did he do this in the
way he has has done it do you would uh
you know this is an odd way perhaps to
put it
if you had been advising him would you
have
once he decided he wanted to invade
would you have advised him to do it in
the way he's done it
well um i come back to my point i made
earlier we are early days i mean if you
think about um the uh invasion of iraq
in
um 2003 by the by the west you know
three or four days into the campaign it
looked pretty awful i have to say i was
part of that
uh invasion um and uh it didn't feel
good from the point of view of the
attackers so i don't think we can yet
conclude that
uh this invasion is in deep trouble
um
but i i do think that um
i would have been advising him not to do
it in the first place you know i i just
i can't see
how
the the thought of an a victory over the
ukraine armed forces is the same thing
as
control of the country that's what i
would have been telling him you'd need
many many many more troops to achieve
the latter
you um were responsible for our cyber
defenses and um
there this conflict may be fought on
uh several different grounds uh uh
under the sea
in cyberspace and in space itself
what other tools does he have at his
disposal and how
uh how well prepared are we to confront
them
so i think we should remember that
russia or its proxies have been
attacking ukraine with cyber for for
many years they uh
took down for example the ukrainian
power grid in 2015 and the
um famous not petcha malware attack in
2017 which was disguised as as
ransomware um but intended to to destroy
data on affected machines had a massive
impact
and and since the last in the last month
and uh increasing the last few days
there have been attacks on on ukrainian
government websites and and on banks and
other government departments so called
wiper attacks where um data is destroyed
or denial of service attacks where
websites are closed down so so that is
not a new tactic for putin and he will
continue to do it
he doesn't need necessarily to intend to
do the same to us for this to cause us
harm i mean taking the example of the
not picture attack which i mentioned a
moment ago
when that happened it was targeted at
ukraine but it had a massive um effect
globally it leaked out of ukraine and
some estimates put the total global cost
of 10 billion dollars so
so so the cyber the use of cyber could
spread outside ukraine
uh arguably more easily than armed
conflict
um as to whether we are better protected
and you know what what we i think we
definitely are the the not petra attack
in particular i think was a wake-up call
for the uk and and we now have
an excellent national cyber security
center which is leading
the defense of
uk systems and we also now have a
national cyber force which is capable of
offensive action in cyberspace
should we be attacked so i think we're
much better off than than we were
and i do think we ought to keep the
cyber risk in perspective as well i you
know you hear a lot of people talking
about
mass cyber attacks i don't think that's
how
cyber really happens um
it's much more likely to cause this
inconvenience and and cost than it is to
kill lots of people
in the end um
general chris do you think that
we need to be more worried about if you
like conventional
uh assault in ukraine and the potential
for that to spread into
the baltic states or nato countries or
these unconventional attacks
you say cyber or maybe the cutting of
undersea cables which we've seen
yeah i mean
and also you know putin is capable of of
um attacking uh our satellites in space
um he's capable of causing or trying to
escalate a massive refugee crisis i mean
there are all kinds of
of non-direct military ways he could um
seek to to expand the crisis but i think
it is worthless thinking very
thoughtfully about
about his ability to expand it with
direct military action i i imagine my
assumption is that he doesn't want to
direct military confrontation with nato
but i don't think we can be certain of
that
there is a risk that he might for
example be seeking to
establish a land bridge um through
either lithuania or poland to the to the
russian enclave on the baltic uh clinton
grad
um or he could be trying to do worse
than that and i mean there is some
evidence that um considerable amounts of
the russian force have not yet entered
ukraine why not
maybe um for logistic reasons but maybe
also because he has purposes in mind
beyond the defeat of ukrainian armed
forces
so i i think it's really important that
nato continues to shout about its
article five commitments and that it it
continues to
[Music]
develop its defence plans as it has done
recently with the activation of the
nato response force which is something
that's not happened before in history
and which many people thought would
never happen
um
so so that is i think the kind of thing
we need to to be doing because we cannot
be certain that he doesn't intend to go
militarily beyond recruit ukraine i
think we can be pretty certain he
intends to have an effect beyond ukraine
but he might even be intending to go
militarily beyond it
general sir chris devral thank you very
much indeed
my pleasure thank you very much trevor
well while ukrainians fight for the
future of their country the uk along
with the us and its allies are limited
to using only economic weapons
all have announced sanctions since the
russian invasion began including a new
round last night targeted at russian
financial institutions
but they faced accusations of each
trying to protect their own economies at
the expense of hitting vladimir putin
where it would really hurt
yesterday before the most recent
announcement i spoke to brian o'toole
from the atlantic council who whilst
working for the u.s treasury was a key
architect of the sanctions against
russia following the annexation of
crimea in 2014
mr so what lessons did you learn from
working on sanctions against russia
in 2014 after the annexation of
crimea
in terms of what was effective and
what didn't work
yeah i mean i think the the sanctions
that are effective
by and large or sanctions where the the
u.s and europe have an asymmetric
balance of power and primarily that's in
the financial sector um the the ones
that don't work it depends on how you
define what work is right i think
um you know the there is a great number
of a great kind of caffeine out there
that says sanctions didn't work because
putin's still in eastern ukraine that
was never really the the goal of the
sanctions in 2014 um but it's true that
uh you know putin is in waging war
against ukraine and um you know the
sanctions haven't deterred him from it
i'm not sure they would have uh any
level of sanctions but it's you know
it's the tool of the west has uh when
they take military action off the table
so that's that's kind of where we are
with the the broad scope of sanctions
effectiveness as it were
well that's an interesting point i mean
what would you say
uh given that the sanctions in 2014 were
in a sense after the fact what would you
say
would be the uh objective of imposing
sanctions in general
so you you always want some sort of
policy outcome right sanctions too many
people think of sanctions as being you
know kind of set it and forget it you
put them on walk away and everything's
taken care of that's not how it works at
all the sanctions in 2014 were designed
for a fairly narrow goal which was to
hopefully stop the expansion of the
the fighting in ukraine kind of freeze
the line of contact as we called it back
then um and buy some space for a
diplomatic negotiation that all happened
right minsk two accords were agreed in
early 2015 they of course have failed to
be implemented since and that's that's a
kind of larger policy issue than than
just the sanctions themselves but
looking from the narrow goal of how we
designed in 2014 they kind of met the
goal
today
there's a kind of difference right there
was some hope at least that sanctions
would would restrain putin's goals here
in ukraine that's that's proven to not
be the case although i think
you know it probably never would have
worked um which is easy to say in
hindsight
the goal now i think as president biden
said the other day is
to constrain and isolate putin and make
him a pariah on the global stage you can
do that politically by
you know sanctioning him as they've done
and preventing him from traveling
cutting off diplomatic contacts things
like that and you can cut off the the
russian economy as well and that's
that's the other part of this is to make
russia pariah with the hope that at some
point in the future
some responsible leader is going to want
to trade
russia stepping on ukraine's neck and oh
by the way trying to step on
kazakhstan's neck and moldova's neck and
george's neck and belarus's neck um
you know that they would trade that
repression
for sanctions really so they could
become part of the global economy again
and i think the challenge is
you know it doesn't save ukraine at the
moment and that's a really hard pill to
swallow when you see zelensky toughing
it out in the fighting and the brave you
know we've got grandma's picking up
you know automatic weapons in ukraine to
go fight on the front and it's uh you
know the heroism of the ukrainian people
i think is uh is extraordinary in this
instance and it's it is unfortunate that
you know as powerful as the us and the
western economies are that it's not
enough to stop
so
to put it straight
what you're really saying is that the
sanctions that are being applied now
really are not going to have any
uh impact in the sense of getting him to
withdraw that story is over that
battle's lost and that any sanctions now
are really about preventing any further
expansion
i think i think that's going to be the
real goal
i will say that on the outside chance
the ukrainians can hold off putin for
some
extended period of time i've seen some
hints on twitter which is always you
know questionably reliable but um some
hints that that russia is running out of
ammunition um running out of you know
kind of the supply chains they've been
pandering for gas panhandling for gas
basically in ukraine
and so
you know
setting aside what's happened after
libya in 2011 sanctions in 2011 against
the qaddafi regime prevented gaddafi
from using a fairly substantial amount
of external wealth to pay for more
things to prosecute his war against his
people if the ukrainian people hold out
long enough sanctions may prevent russia
from rearming itself
um because putin will lack the money he
will lack the supplies
um and he will lack you know to a
certain extent the morale within his
troops that seems to be kind of on the
edge of the moment so
there's an outside chance of that but i
wouldn't put a ton of hope in it um you
know russia does still have overwhelming
force
uh so you know i do think that the
broader goal is
containment and isolation over a longer
period of time than than ukrainian
people can probably hold off a russian
advance
what is the period over which we might
want to look for
if you like
some change in the russian stance i mean
are we talking days or weeks or months
that if the ukrainians can hold out for
a period
that they might change the outcome
i think you're probably looking at at
weeks to months for the kind of military
aspect um
you know if russia is indeed running out
of ammunition and weapons then that's
that's not easily replaceable and this
starts to drag out further and the
economic pain can take a bigger bite out
of the russian economy and maybe
cause some rethinking in moscow
again i don't hold out great hopes for
that i think the more likely scenario is
months to years um is is the is the kind
of longer term outlook and you know look
realistically it's when putin is is on
his way out um and or is out of power
do you think that there is
a problem
that there are too many countries who
uh stand to lose too much if they really
took action against uh russia
it's certainly a factor um whether it's
a problem
depends a little bit you know one of the
things that that i've tried to reiterate
to folks is that you know u.s sanctions
by themselves have something like
75
of of the impact that sanctions that the
u.s and eu take jointly and the reason
is because the u.s financial system is
so dominant in global markets that most
eu banks are just going to kind of go
along right so
it makes the united states decisions
kind of increasingly are kind of
inherently much more powerful than than
anything than anybody else out there and
that can kind of pull the eu along if
the eu does not do the same exact set of
sanctions because of the 27 member
states that they have to convince some
of which have
different relationships with russia than
than others
um
the more important thing in my view is
ensuring kind of a continuity of
messages and this is something that was
discussed a lot in the run-up to the the
war itself but
you know the the basic theory that i'm
going off of is that if u.s sanctions
can be three-quarters of the the total
impact um even without the eu doing it
what matters at the end of the day then
is if the russians turn the eu and say
it's unfair that the u.s sanctioned
spare bank
um the eu will say
yeah we didn't do that but you still
need to get the hell out of ukraine um
if that's the message and the u.s and eu
are kind of united on the messaging
front
then that's plenty of impact in the long
run uh and looking at your own
experience
uh what you've done in this field
that there is always a
potential danger and perhaps even a
general rule
that sanctions can end up hurting those
who apply them just as much or even more
than those that they're supposed to
influence
it's an absolutely fair point and that's
what policymakers weigh when they impose
sanctions um the u.s imposed kind of
financing restrictions on gazprom
earlier this week the major russian gas
company and president biden didn't even
mention it in his remarks clearly
because what he was trying to do was
calm the nerves
of financial markets
and
that is you know the sanctions were not
going to interrupt you know delivery of
gas or anything like that so it was it
was a reasonable attack
i think when you design sanctions and
think about implementing them you
absolutely want to think of the blowback
the whole point is to hurt the other guy
more than you're hurting yourself um and
sometimes you can hurt yourself more if
you're not careful um if the us suddenly
went out tomorrow and put full blocking
restrictions on on ross neff and trying
to present prevent rosneft from uh
shipping oil around the world that would
have major ramifications for global
growth including in the united states
and europe um so they are of course not
going to do that they're going to try to
find other ways to use an asymmetric
balance of power and rely on that
asymmetry to
to
have the effect that they want without
the spillover
all in all taking all of this together
uh you said
uh a moment ago that you thought this
might be the end of putinism if you had
it if you had to put a bet on it put a
probability
how close are we to that outcome
i you know look i i
i'm probably clouded a little bit by
hope as much as as rational thinking on
this if i'm being honest but
i think this is the beginning of the end
um i don't know how long it'll take but
to me
this is putin overextending himself in a
way that he did not overextend himself
in 2014. um you know his his approval
rating is not at 80 or 90 percent the
way it was in 2014 um it's significantly
lower he's got a smaller
cabal of people that he he listens to
and to a certain extent answers to
um he seems more isolated especially in
the world stage now the whole country is
isolated stage this is a very different
circumstance in 2014 and i i do tend to
think that it's this is the start of the
end how long that takes is
is kind of beyond my powers to predict
for sure um and but you know it uh i do
think this is kind of that beginning
well let's get the latest now from on
the ground uh security and defense
editor deborah haynes is in kiev
good morning deborah what are we hearing
now about the russian advance
good morning well actually in the centre
of kiev we're not we're literally not
hearing much and that's because this
very strict curfew has been slapped on
everybody who's not in the security
forces in this city from uh yesterday
evening and through until tomorrow
morning at eight o'clock you literally
are not allowed outside and that's
because there are fears that there are
russian teams covert operators irregular
forces in the city and the ukrainians
are trying to to capture them find find
them the concern being that while yes
the the overt large-scale russian attack
that is clearly has been planned for
this city though it's
definitely stalled somewhat um it has
been stopped for the uh these smaller
irregular teams they've obviously been
able to slip in it would seem into the
city and actually the uk's defense
ministry it's been putting up these
really useful uh intelligence updates
from its intelligence arm and its latest
one uh talks specifically about this
issue and says that ukrainian forces
have engaged what it describes as the
remnants of russian irregular forces
within kiev for a second night uh saying
that the uh the fighting
last night was actually at a lower level
than the night before and it was
incredibly tense last night there were
these warnings that went out about a
possible large-scale russian air raid on
the city at one point we were all um
told to go down into the basement of the
hotel where we're staying um but
unusually there weren't any air air
sirens at that time so after about an
hour or so we all kind of were allowed
to come back to our rooms but it gives
an indication really of this strange
sense that we're all living in at the
moment where you have air sirens there
are air strikes we've had apartment
blocks being hit by missiles but the
ukrainian defense itself of the capital
has so far managed to prevent the the
russian forces from advancing though we
are hearing reports today from ukraine's
second city of kharkiv which is in the
east of the country with russian forces
now in that city battling with the
ukrainian troops
it's it's clearly still a large-scale
invasion going on but it's also clearly
not going to the time scale that
president putin had wanted and that's
significant because the longer an
invading force stays on foreign
territory without achieving achieving
the objectives it set itself and its
supply chains for then the harder it
does get for that invading force and
that's why it seems you've got the
ukrainians still rallying their defenses
even today announcing the creation of
effectively a foreign legion so asking
for international volunteers who might
want to come and sign up to go to their
embassies in their respective countries
and come and fight
deborah thank you so much and uh
come back safely
let's get some more political reaction
now
alicia kearns is a conservative mp who
sits on the commons foreign affairs
select committee
good morning uh miss kearns good morning
the prime minister announced this week
the largest set of economic
sanctions against russia now jeremy hunt
the former foreign secretary said
economic sanctions would not go far
enough and that a quote fundamental
review of our military capability was
needed um do you agree what's your
assessment of the
uk's reaction to what has happened
i think we all know at the start of the
week i was calling for us to go faster
and harder in terms of the sanctions we
put in place but i think what we are
absolutely seeing is the uk leading from
the front um i called at the start of
the week for a ban on all russian banks
for us to be looking at dealing with uh
rushed access to the boss for us uh
making sure we really put in place these
meaningful strikes and sanctions and
that is what they've done and crucially
when i speak to my counterparts across
the world when i speak to mps in ukraine
and when i speak to those on g7 calls
they're very clear that it's boris
johnson who's been leading from the
front and really pushing for meaningful
action on this
so you think that what he's done is uh
appropriate and uh
pretty much as far as he can go of
course i was talking to the foreign
secretary earlier this morning and we
were discussing the price that we as a
country would have to pay gas and petrol
and food prices
surged after the invasion and the
chair of your committee foreign affairs
committee said that the cost of living
will be driven by
war
um
same question i asked liz trust really
what are you
going to say to people who are already
struggling to pay their bills
and worried that this invasion of
ukraine
will only make the cost of living crisis
worse
i think we have to have a really adult
conversation with every single member of
the british public and this is something
that we haven't done for decades we've
always told the public that national
security issues are too difficult too
complicated we've infantilized them i
think what we're seeing this week is the
government saying yes there is going to
be a cost yes ukraine is the breadbasket
of europe and yes war is going to drive
up our costs but when i walked around my
constituency over the last few days
people haven't been saying to me i'm
worried about break prices i'm worried
about this of course they are but what
they're mainly worried about is war in
europe what they're mainly worried about
is the scenes they're seeing of children
having been shipped out of their homes
of attacks using cluster bombs on
civilian sites and they all recognize
this isn't just ukraine under attack
this is all our values and this is the
western world order so i think we have
to have an adult conversation but i'm
absolutely confident the british people
are behind us and they know it's going
to be not very easy for the next few
months
that is indeed what the foreign
secretary said but the foreign secretary
also said
that she thought that for the last 15
years
we've been too soft
on putin
the smart member of the public might say
you guys basically failed
in
dealing with this man and now you're
expecting us to pay the price
look i've been very clear since i became
a member of parliament that for too long
there have been no consequences for
putin's actions he continually ratchets
and ratchets and ratchets and there's
been no meaningful response to what he's
done and that's why what we've seen at
the back end of this week has been so
important you know the news yesterday
we've managed to bring the entire
international community to agree to
banning swift something the uk's wants
to do and it's taking diplomacy to get
them in line for and the fact that the
restrictions the russian central bank
now that is a true
economic strike on the russian
government they've got about 300 billion
of gold reserves abroad that is going to
affect their liquidity they will not be
able to access the cash they need and
that's when banks fail when you starve
them and i agree the international
community has been too soft on putin but
that is an international effort and even
if we have been stronger on putin if he
had decided to invade ukraine as he has
and i genuinely don't believe he could
have been deterred looking at what we've
seen there would still have been these
immediate costs as they always are when
war unfortunately comes to our
neighborhood
uh general sir chris deveral made um i
think an interesting point in our
conversation with him that
this could spread in various ways well
one way i know that um your committee
has been keeping an eye on
is uh what happens to the east of russia
that is to say china and one ally that
mr putin might have thought he could
rely on is china but on friday china
abstained on the un
security council
vote do you think that's a blow to
russia
without question we have to remember
that what we have that putin doesn't is
a constellation of alliances around the
world whether it's orcas or nato or five
eyes that is what makes us strongest and
that's what's made a difference the last
few days now i do believe that we have
seen a limiting of the worst excesses of
putin's military arms his military
capabilities what we are seeing is
heartbreaking but it is not the absolute
destruction devastation he could have
brought straight away and i believe
that's because of the economic cost and
unity we're seeing across the world but
what i think we're seeing from xi
jinping is he doesn't have any appetite
for this there is no benefit to him of
ukraine coming back under the russian
fold um and i think he is absolutely
nervous about this and so i welcome the
fact that china hasn't taken action but
we still shouldn't be praising them
because absolutely behind the scenes
they could be agreeing to all sorts of
further agreements and i think in fact
that china agreed to provide some wheat
supplies to putin only at the start of
this week so what china does publicly
and what they do behind the scenes are
two very different things and we should
be keeping an eye on both
alisa kurz thank you very much for your
time this morning
vladimir putin spent years suppressing
opposition groups in russia but there
has nonetheless been opposition to the
invasion on the streets of russian
cities this weekend raising the question
of whether he may have misjudged the
willingness of the russian people to
support a campaign against their
neighbors and relatives
yesterday i spoke to vladimir karamosa a
leading russian opposition politician
what can you tell us about the scale of
anti-war demonstrations in russia
well earlier this week there were
thousands of people who came out onto
the streets all over the country more
than 50 cities across russia uh there
were nearly 2 000 arrests made in one
single evening as people all over this
country are saying not in our name this
is not our war and this is a very
important message that i hope is heard
around the world this is not russia's
war this is not the war by the people of
russia on the people of ukraine this is
yet another military adventure by the
unaccountable unelected authoritarian
and frankly increasingly deranged
dictator in a kremlin by the name of
vladimir putin and it's not just the
thousands of russians who have been
protesting despite the threat and the
very real risk of arrest and and and
everything else that can can happen if
you're opposing the putin regime here
but uh also russia's leading cultures
figures uh writers scientists uh sports
people journalists have been adding
their voices over these past few days uh
to the growing protest here in russia
against uh putin's war
well i was going to ask you who are the
protesters are they
simply students and intellectuals which
we've seen a lot of in the past
no the protesters it is true that they
are mostly young and i think this is a
very important sign because vladimir
putin is going to turn 70 this year and
those russians are coming out to protest
against his regime and against this war
that he's unleashed are mostly young
people and they are the future of russia
and he isn't today is the uh seventh
anniversary of the assassination of
russian opposition leader boris nemtsov
who was gunned down literally in front
of the kremlin walls in moscow
well
you were in fact a close associate of mr
nemtsov and
uh i guess
this says that there is a price to pay
for protesting
in mr putin's russia you yourself i
think have faith reprisals
well i've been poisoned twice by
operatives of the russian fsb the
federal security service the same
operatives who later poisoned alexander
there were a series of
media investigations uh led by bellycat
at your london-based media group that
has
uh conducted this you know amazing
investigative journalism and actually
uncovered the names of the operatives of
putin's fsb
uh that uh you know the go around
killing political opponents of the putin
regime both alexander navalny
and i were fortunate you know when i was
lying in a coma here in hospital moscow
after the poisoning uh doctors told my
wife that i had about a five percent
chance
to survive i cannot
tell you enough how grateful i am to
have made that five percent but you know
boris nemtsov did not even have one
percent chance when that russian
interior ministry officer shot him in
the back on that bridge in front of the
kremlin every year
thousands of people come to that bridge
to chile flowers to to light candles to
pay their respects this year for the
first time uh the authorities here have
made it clear that they will not be
allowing the memorial event uh of course
you know nothing can prohibit and nobody
can prohibit me from going to pay
respects to the memory of my slain
friend so i will of course be going to
the bridge to chile flowers whatever
happens
the west has decided that uh the best
path to changing mr putin's behavior is
to attack his personal wealth
and standing can you give us
an idea of
basically just how rich is putin and um
where did that money come from
well mr putin has for a long time now
being described by various media
organizations and experts as probably
the richest man in the world and i very
well can believe that because
don't forget the regime that putin
established here in russia is not just
authoritarian but it's also kleptocratic
you know from the classic definition of
kleptocracy ruled by thieves uh and of
course what those people like to do the
people who are in and around the premier
is to steal the money here from our
people in russia and then stash it away
and spend it
in western countries in western banks
western jurisdictions western financial
institutions where that money is
protected by the very same rule of law
that they are denying our own people
here in russia what would happen
if this actually did change his behavior
um
it is possible that he might be
compelled to realize
that he's miscalculated and that he now
needs to back off
but i think some experts also say
that it is entirely possible that he
might realize he's miscalculated and
simply double down i think trying to
predict what vladimir putin will do is
by this stage more in the realm of
psychoanalysis than political analysis
so it's difficult if not impossible to
say uh what is very clear though is that
the international community the free
world the community of democracy should
finally better later never again stand
firm stand in a position of principle
against this man against this criminal
corrupt and authoritarian regime and
what we do know from the history of
russia
is that those so-called small victorious
wars
uh that are
launched by russian and soviet rulers
for their own domestic political
purposes and to try to divert domestic
attention away from the real problems
that people are facing here at home
um
those small victorious walls don't have
a very good track record frankly and
very often they actually have
the effect that was the exact opposite
of what was intended i mean just think
back to the crimean war in the 19th
century how that ended for this
aristocracy the russo-japanese war of
the early 20th century and how that
ended for the zarya's autocracy of
course the soviet invasion of
afghanistan in the late 20th century and
what that did to the communist party of
the soviet union so um you know i
mentioned already that this this is not
russia's war this is a personal military
crime a personal military adventure uh
by vladimir putin yet another in the
long list uh but you know what this one
may well prove to be his last
you're right you quote the history but
of course one of the lessons of that
history is that uh
russian leaders seem to try it again and
again crimea
uh hungary czechoslovakia chechnya
afghanistan
crimea again and now
ukraine do you think
that
putin
is capable
and
willing uh
in any circumstances
to fight this war
uh beyond ukraine and into european
territory perhaps even on nato territory
well you've already heard him actually
threaten the use of nuclear weapons
earlier this week so again this this man
is deranged he could do anything uh but
i think what was also important to say
is that every example you just mentioned
of sort of foreign aggression that
russian or soviet rulers
were engaged in all those examples come
from uh the times when russia or the
soviet union uh were autocratic uh
domestically you know in those brief
periods of time when russia was a
democracy such as for example in the
early 1990s
the russian leadership the russian
people stood for example in solidarity
with the baltic states in the early 90s
when uh the soviet leadership tried to
send tanks into lithuania so there's a
really important lesson here that there
is a direct correlation between the
domestic and the foreign russia between
the domestic repression and the lack of
democracy here at home and the external
aggression that the kremlin engages in
there will come a time there will come a
time when
the politics start changing in russia
when the political situation starts
changing because there are millions of
people in russia who fundamentally and
categorically reject everything that the
putin regime stands for who wants who
want russia to become a normal modern
democratic european country uh that it
should be
and you know when that day comes which
none of us can predict because another
lesson from russian history is that
major political changes uh in russia can
happen like this you know suddenly and
unexpectedly when that day comes i think
that will be a very good day not just
for us here in russia for obvious
reasons but also for the rest of the
world and for the rest of europe
well far away from the conflict zone
vulnerable people across the world and
in the uk are likely to feel increased
pressure from higher fuel bills higher
food prices and potentially higher
interest rates as central banks try to
contain soaring inflation
let's speak to the economist vicky price
who was formerly joint head of the
united kingdom's government's economic
service good morning vicki um
the global economy was already pretty
fragile
what is this invasion going to do to it
well what the global economy was uh
facing just before the invasion was
already higher prices for
oil and gas that
reflected up to point concern what putin
might be doing or intending to do
but also of course a very substantial
increase in demand
because obviously when you're taking
away restrictions
so quickly actually that has happened in
some countries and you have already
given an awful lot of cash to
individuals during that period with a
with massive monetary expansion and
fiscal expansion
then you expect that demand to try and
find a way to uh be spent you know so
the money will be spent on supplies
which have been very hard to come by and
that has been a problem generally so
we've had supply chain issues we've had
pent up demand that
has caused quite a lot of commodities to
go up in price
industry has been facing one of the
largest increases in their costs for
themselves for 30 years not just the
individuals who are seeing inflation
rise to highest 40 years and that has
been reflected of course in consumer
price inflation
and
in addition
unfortunately to electricity prices
which are rising as well and rising
quite substantially and gas prices for
individuals so the householders are
affected disproportionately in some ways
uh by a combination of all these things
that are going on including i'm afraid
in this country an increase in taxes
which is likely to take place in april
when national insurance contributions go
up so if you put it all together you
have a consumer with disposable incomes
shrinking and likely to shrink even
further because of the ukraine crisis
and on top of that of course will be the
effect of sanctions uh because we've
been talking about that this morning and
it's obvious that sanctions are never a
one-way street uh
russians may retaliate but in any event
there'll be
costs to us for example
car production russia is one of the
world's largest suppliers of metal
used in the car production could
sanctions
add a further twist to that spiral
yes economically sanctions of course
hurt both sides
and there's no doubt that europe is
going to suffer because indeed as you
rightly say
russia also exports an awful lot of
aluminium
also primary iron ore
also minerals all sorts of minerals come
out of of russia and of course
additionally wheat and also from the
ukraine uh so people are already
worrying about beer prices going up
bread prices going up and indeed more
supply shortages in various areas like
as you mentioned car production which
has been hit quite significantly because
of
shortages of semiconductors anyway um
and if you also affect the the basic
production
uh inputs that are needed then obviously
costs go up and
uh the the producers suffer as i was
saying before the
the costs the input costs for
producers have gone up significantly and
we talk a lot about households but it's
good that you mention it
manufacturing particularly energy
intensive industries are suffering right
now and they will suffer more yes i'm
afraid uh the the pain will be twofold
it would be
over here and over there by which i mean
russia as well
uh you mentioned the uh
effect on inflation um a moment ago some
people are now talking
um about eight percent inflation at a
time when wage writers
are going to be less than half that um
what do you think the impact of that is
is going to be
the the forecast now are assuming of
course that gas and oil prices
move even higher than where they are at
present i mean remember they did move
above certainly for oil above a hundred
dollars a barrel to 105 and then they
came back again so they're hovering in
the 90s somewhere but they could of
course go up again particularly given
the the swift um
controls that have just been announced
uh in other words that the banks are not
good the russian banks aren't going to
be able to be part of the whole system
but all that of course then means uh
inevitably that um
you end up with
uh um
inflation being not just seven by seven
and a half percent as we thought in
april but maybe eight percent eight and
a half percent will that then lead to
the the authorities here if you like the
central banks in particular and
elsewhere because in the us we already
have seven and a half percent inflation
and we'll be moving higher too
raising interest rates even more than
what they had anticipated and there is
actually an argument that that isn't
going to happen that what will happen is
that we're going to look again at
whether in fact higher interest rates
would have any impact on all this at all
and maybe therefore we will have um
interest rates
uh not rising anything like as fast as
have been anticipated so there could be
a little bit of support that is given to
businesses in addition i think the
governments are going to have to borrow
a little bit more and support households
okay
vicky uh thank you so so much uh looking
for a silver lining there but
pretty gloomy but thank you so much for
your time this morning
thank you
that's all that we have time for this
morning no doubt
we will be in a very different position
again next week
sky will continue to cover what is
happening out there stay with us for the
time for this morning
should chastity to people of ukraine
good luck and doth vidanya goodbye
[Music]